la fête de l'internet se termine ce soir
pour clôturer cette semaine du web 150
enfants se sont retrouvés hier au sénat
pour un grand jeu sur ordinateur natalys
à penafiel y sera séances animées ce
samedi dans l'hémicycle du sénat à la
place des élus 150 élèves de zones
d'éducation prioritaire venus de toute
la france pour jouer à une sorte de
questions pour un champion
le but chercher sur internet la réponse
à une question
derrière le jeu et la fête de l'internet
il y à la lutte contre les inégalités en
matière d'équipement informatique vous
pensez qu'aujourd'hui il existe vraiment
une fracture numérique existe
darty qui ne sont pas ou quasi pas l'om
je pense avoir internet à la maison
c'est aujourd'hui le rêve de nombreux
enfants qui savent même à onze ans que
la réussite professionnelle passe par la
maîtrise de cet outil
rachid était camarades de l'école de
berbizier se classe en troisième
position
bon résultat car aucun des trois ne
possède d'ordinateur à la maison